bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir et de revoir les temps
forts de la dernière session
parlementaire avec un focus aujourd'hui
sur le projet de loi Macron projet de
loi croissance activité égalité des
chances économique un texte qui a été
définitivement adopté par le Parlement
le 10 juillet dernier mais qui avait
donné lieu à des échanges nourris que
cela soit au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée
nationale je vous propose aujourd'hui de
revenir à l'examen en deuxè lecture de
ce texte au Sénat avec notamment les
discussions des sénateurs autour de la
libéralisation du secteur des transports
notamment celui des autocars objectif du
gouvernement avec la libéralisation de
Cees secteurs créer 22000 nouveaux
emplois lors de l'examen du texte et
bien les discussions avaient surtout
porté sur le seuil en dessous duquel il
était encore limité ou interdit de faire
des liaisons par autocard le
gouvernement voulait un seuil fixé à 200
km les sinateur étaient eux favorabl à
un stage fixé à 100 km tout de suite
donc retour au débat dans l'hémicycle
madame Annique billon a demandé la
parole pour le groupe udi
UC madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je tiens
ici à rappeler les amendements que
j'avais déposés en première lecture
concernant l'expérimentation d'une
ouverture à la concurrence mais je le
soulligne à nouveau une concurrence
encadrée sous forme de délégation de
service public depuis la commission
avenir des trains équilibre des
territoires au sein de laquelle j'étais
parlementaire en mission pendant 6 mois
a produit son rapport le rapport dit
Duron a fait l'objet d'un débat au Sénat
le 9 juin dernier mais nous sommes dans
l'attente de la feuille de route du
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez
monsieur le ministre pour ma part je
préconise une interaction des Tet et des
TER pour une meilleure efficience
économique d'une part et une meilleure
qualité à nos concitoyens d'autre part
vous le savez les conventions entre les
régions et la SNCF ont pour la plupart
été prolongées d'un an pour raison
d'élection régionale or l'article 1
quinquè anticipe le calendrier européen
de quelques mois en avançant au 1er
janvier 2019 la possibilité pour les
régions autorité organisatrice
d'attribuer tout ou partie de ces
conventions à une entreprise ferroviaire
titulaire de la licence mentionné à
l'article
l2122-10 du code des transports si
j'entends bien que la réponse sera
complexe ma question est simple monsieur
le ministre le gouvernement
accepterait-il sur les lignes Tet les
plus menacées de lancer un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt et d'avancer la
date d'expérimentation d'une concurrence
en cadré pour les TER qui en complètent
l'offre je vous remercie merci beaucoup
chers collègues nous avons maintenant
dans la discussion de l'article 1er
quinquè deux amendements identiques le
premier est présenté par Monsieur
dezessard c'est le 17
oui l'article 1 ququè adopté au Sénat en
première lecture supprimé à l'Assemblée
et réintroduit en commission spéciale
propose de mettre fin au monopole de
SNCF mobilité pour le transport
ferroviaire régional le règlement
européen sur les obligations de service
public règlement OSP adapté en 2009
prévoit d'instaurer un cadre légal en
matière d'octroit de compensation et ou
de droits exclusif pour les contrats de
service public en d'autres termes il
laisse la liberté de choix au région de
choisir entre plusieurs options mise en
régie attribution directe du contrat ou
appel d'ofre et il doit entrer en
vigueur en 2019 l'article 1 qu'què
n'apporte rien par rapport à ce
règlement il se contente de redire
presque exactement la même chose au-delà
des inquiétudes de forme cet article
apporte une réponse discutable à la mise
en concurrence du train par le car tel
que prévu par le présent projet de loi
en somme les auteurs de cet article
estiment que puisque le car est
désormais libéralisé il faut en faire de
même pour le train en faisant cela vous
condamnez d'avance les lignes qui ne
seront pas rentables et vous acceptez
que le train régional perde son rôle
dans l'aménagement du territoire cet
article nous sommes injustifiés voire
dangereux pour la ement du territoire
c'est pourquoi nous proposons sa
suppression je vous
remercie monsieur Bolino vous avez la
parole monsieur le squarnc pardon pour
le 77
excusez-moi merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les membres du groupe CRC sont opposés à
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire national de
voyageurs disposition qui avait été
justement supprimé par l'Assemblée
nationale nous ne partageons pas l'idée
que la concurrencem permettra de réduire
les coûts et d'améliorer la qualité de
service du transport ferroviaire et
aidera à préserver son attractivité par
rapport au transport routier comme il a
été rappelé cet article fait du
règlement européen
P obligation de service public une
interprétation erronée car aujourd'hui
c'est l'État qui a une compétence
décisionnelle délégué aux régions certes
mais encadré ainsi par le biais de la
loi d'orientation des transports
intérieurs la lotie et de la loi
relative à la solidarité et
renouvellement urbain loi seru le
monopole du transport régional
ferroviaire est attribué à la SNCF ce
que les régions ne peuvent remettre en
cause et cela est conforme au règlement
OSP à cet égard le Parlement européen a
repoussé l'échéance de mise en
concurrence des lignes conventionnées de
2019 à 2022 comme cela a été souligné
sur nos bans déjà de plus les modalités
d'ouverture à la concurrence ne sont pas
définis et reste à négocier en proposant
une entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier
2019 vous continuez à démanteler le
service public ferroviaire bien entendu
nous ne sous-estimons pas les
difficultés rencontrées par les usagers
sur de nombreux trajets toutefois il
nous semble évident que seul un
investissement public fort permettrait
de relever le défi des transports de
demain la finalité du système
ferroviaire ne doit pas être la
concurrence ni même l'émergence de
nouveaux opérateurs son objectif doit
être de répondre aux besoins
grandissants des usagers d' transport de
qualité fiable ponctuel et en toute
sécurité ainsi que de contribuer par le
rééquilibrage modal à la nécessaire
transition écologique et énergétique
c'est pourquoi nous proposons la
suppression de cet
article merci quel est l'avis du
de de la commission pardon madame le
rapporteur alors madame la Présidente
comme l'ont rappelé les deux personnes
qui ont présenté ces amendements le
débat a largement eu lieu en première
lecture ici même dans l'hémicycle et
donc comme ce n'est pas la lecture qu'a
choisi le Sénat et bien l'avis est
défavorable sur ces deux
amendements monsieur le ministre je vous
en prie oui merci Madame présidente
j'aurais un avis favorable sur ces deux
amendements pour les raisons
précédemment évoqué je voulais répondre
à madame la sénatrice pour indiquer ici
que le rapport durond donc auquel vous
avez contribué a été donc remis fin juin
et propose des mesures ciblées d' plus
ciblées qu n leçon dans le le présent
article d'ouverture à la concurrence des
en particulier des lignes de nuit et mon
collègue Alain vidalis communiquera le 7
juillet sur les suites que le
gouvernement compte donner donc à vos
propositions avec toujours cet équilibre
entre les contraintes en particulier
économiques de l'État àô et les
contraintes en termees de desserte du
territoire mais c'est dans cet équilibre
que des propositions concrètes seront
faites sur la base du rapport qui a été
remis fin
juin bien merci alors pour explication
de vote j'ai d'abord monsieur raison qui
a la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
suivrai l'avis de notre rapporteur d're
excellente rapporteur parce que d'abord
il y a deux sujets différents la
concurrence ferroviaire pure et ce qu'on
peut appeler la concurrence routière par
rapport au fer c'est un autre sujet mais
la SNCF est une entreprise et la SNCF
est une excellente entreprise avec des
qualités incontestable par rapport à
beaucoup d'autres pays son seul mal sa
seule souffrance c'est d'avoir le
monopole et c'est un service à rendre à
la SNCF que d'ouvrir la concurrence j'ai
été dans une vie antérieure chargé des
transports régionaux dans ma région on
avait d'excellentes relation avec l' NCF
mais qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu rêver
pouvoir avoir un concurrent pour pouvoir
stimuler la SNCF pour pouvoir favoriser
l'offre de services nouveaux d'idées
nouvelles de combinaisons nouvelles et
je dis que même le fret
ferroviaire souffre de non concurrence
moi j'ai vu des vrais fret ferroviaires
sur de la longue distance avec des
trains entiers abandonnés par la SNCF
parce qu'il y avait des complexités à
l'intérieur même de l'entreprise sur
lesqueles je ne m'étendrai pas mais la
SNCF pour survivre pour s'améliorer a
besoin d'être stimulé a besoin de
concurrence elle n'a rien à craindre
elle sera stimulée elle a un bon
savoir-faire donc elle pourra facilement
s'en sortir donc évidemment je suis
défavorable à cet amendement il a
Monsieur Hervé Moret a la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre mais mes chers collègues un
petit peu dans dans le même esprit que
ce qu'a dit Monsieur raison moi je je ne
voterai naturellement pas ces ces
amendements qui ont été proposés et je
me réjouis au contraire que la
commission spéciale a réintroduit dans
le texte cette ouverture à la
concurrence le le 1er janvier 2019 ça
avait été supprimé à l'Assemblée
nationale l'Assemblée nationale argant
du fait que nous étions encore dans le
cadre de la discussion du 4e paquet
ferroviaire mais la réalité c'est que
les textes européens permettent déjà
cette ouverture qu'il qu'ils sont déjà
prévus par les textes européens à effet
du 3 décembre 2019 et le fait
d'anticiper cette cette ouverture
j'avais même pour ma part proposé en
première lecture qu'on anticipe au 1er
janvier 2018 le fait d'anticiper cette
ouverture à concurrence ne peut être que
positive on voit ce qui s'est passé en
Allemagne avec l'ouverture à la
concurrence loin de nuire au ferroviair
et loin même de nuire à l'entreprise
publique du ferroviaire ça a tout à fait
amélioré les choses et et quand et quand
mon mon collègue explique que ce serait
dangereux en matière d'aménagement du
territoire je crois que ce qui s'est
passé en Allemagne montre l'inverse donc
il y a besoin de cette concurrence pour
le ferroviaire et elle est d'autant plus
nécessaire avec la concurrence des
autocars qui vont venir c'est d'autant
plus nécessaire que le secteur
ferroviaire soit ouvert à la concurrence
donc je ne voterai pas ces amendements
merci monsieur Alain Bertrand a la
parole oui moi je suis de bien sûr de la
vie de monsieur le ministre sur sur cet
amendement mais il y a des choses
extraordinaires le rapport du rôle il
est bien fait bon il dit qu'il y a des
fois il faut fusionner transport express
régionaux les traains d'équilibre du
territoire mais on s'aperçoit aussi que
la snsf sur des lignes par exemple où on
avait pas de Fra bois nous LAZER Le
sevenol quand ça a été ouvert à la
concurrence
et bien les compagnies privées
transportent des des trains complets de
de bois par contre cette semaine avec la
présidente du conseil général Sophie
Pantel nouvellement élu c'est le seul
conseil général qui est passé de droite
à gauche en lozer on a rencontré le
directeur régional de la SNCF alors je
le dis à mes amis aussi communistes
parce que je déf le train bien sûr parce
qu'il y a des endroits où si on
maintient pas c train d'équilibre du
territoire il y aura rien mais second
l'a rencontré alors je vous dis pas son
nom il est directeur régional de la CNCF
et on lui dit mais le cvenol vous nous
dites qu'il y a peu de client mais il y
a plus personne dans les gares il est
pas indiqué ni à Paris ni à Lyon donc
personne peut savoir qu'il existe
euh il y a pas de contrôleur dans les
trains donc même quand il y a des
passagers on peut pas les comptabiliser
il payent pas et le gars il nous a
répondu directeur rionnal de la
SNCF écoutez je vais étudier pour que
vous soyez affiché sur Les Bordes
électroniques le sevenol donc c'est
clairement ferant Nim Marseille mais
vous savez avec le système informatique
qu'on a Paris SNCF et tout c'est même
pas sûr que vous puissiez être affiché
sur Les Bordes électroniques dans toute
la France donc quand quelqu'un veut le
prendre aujourd'hui ici en France en
2015 monsieur le ministre et ben il peut
même par le vendre et il faut pas dire
que les trains d'équilibre du territoire
monsieur vidaliè regardera bon avec
perspicacité je suis sur ce cas faut pas
dire que ça relève que de la SNCF parce
que l'État intervient quand même auprès
de la SNCF pour injecter des finances
sur cette partie traain équilibre du
territoire donc soyons vigilants et mais
c'est sûr qu'on peut pas non plus
maintenir les trains qui circulent la
vide en permanence partout et et à
beaucoup d'endroits voilà
monsieur Bertrand donc je vais mettre au
voie l'amendement numéro
et Madame
David madame Didier je suis vraiment
fatigué
oui merci Madame la PR la présidente
rapidement pour dire que la comparaison
avec l'Allemagne mon cher président de
la
commission ça ça vaut à condition qu'on
dise que l'Allemagne elle n'a pas laissé
la
dette initiale à
laadb et donc qu'on est parti tout de
même dans des conditions un petit peu
différentes quand au train évoqué par
notre collègu vous ne me ferez pas
croire que les concurrents vont venir
sur quelque chose de parentable alors
votre
système ne prend pas en compte
l'ensemble des données et
donc alors parce que effectivement on
mais ça a renforcé laadb parce qu'on a
tout fait pour que l'opérateur principal
reste mettre chez lui pour pour dire les
choses en ouvrant effectivement la
concurrence sur le T le choix a été
différent dans un ordre différent mais
surtout on n' pas laissé la dette aux
opérateurs historiques hein je pense que
ça il faut quand même pas l'oublier
c'est ce qui plombe aujourd'hui la isncf
que ce soit mobilité ou ou
RFF mobilité parce que du coup on paye
beaucoup plus cher les réseaux les
sillons et et et RFF évidemment qui qui
peut à peine investir aujourd'hui donc
je crois qu'il faut arrêter des
comparaisons qui ne sont pas euh
justes qui ne sont pas raison tout à
fait et et donc pour revenir à la
concurrence vous savez très bien que la
concurrence va se porter sur les lignes
rentables et pas sur les autres et donc
on aura toujours ce problème
d'aménagement du territoire là où il n'y
a pas forcément rentabilité et et notre
collègue souligne un point effectivement
un train qui n'est pas répertorié dans
les listings a peu de chance d'être
emprunté euh voilà c'est un peu comme
les bureaux de poste où on réduit le
nombre d'heures évidemment les gens n
viennent moins parce que c'est moins
pratique donc on réduit encore les
heures on connaît le truc enfin je il y
a une manière de tuer le
service merci beaucoup chers collègues
je mets au voix les amendements 17 et 77
avec avis défavorable de la commission
et favorable du gouvernement qui qui est
pour 17 19 20 21 21
22 qui est
contre 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
il pas adopté ils ne sont pas
adoptés je mets au voix l'article 1er
quinquèe qui est
pour il faut qu'on compte
là 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 30 2
alors bon quiz
contre 1 2 3 4 5 6
hein l'article est
adopté
article 2 je crois que le rapporteur
veut prendre la parole je vous en prie
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais prendre la parole rapidement
parce qu'on a beaucoup échangé sur cette
question du seuil de licent à 100 ou 200
km oui madame brick donc pour vous faire
part de mon incompréhension face à la
volonté monsieur le ministre que vous
avez exprimé de rétablir coûte que coûte
un seuil glissant de 100 km alors alors
que le Sénat l'a fixé à 200 km et qu'il
s'agit bien d'un seuil glissant et non
pas d'un seuil fixe nous avons
simplement changé le chiffre 100 km et
nous avons nous mis un seuil glissant à
200 km je rappelle que c'est l'autorité
de la concurrence qui a préconisé la
fixation de ce seuil glissant car nous
parlons bien d'un seuil glissant après
avoir mesurer jusqu'à quelle distance la
concurrence entre les modes ferroviaires
et routiers et la plus forte il s'agit
donc d'une mesure importante pour
protéger les services ferroviaires
largement subventionnés par l'État et
par les régions l'enjeu vous le voyez
monsieur le ministre est autant
écologique qu'économique si vous
choisissez de rétablir à nouveau le
seuil de 100 km comme l'a fait
l'Assemblée nationale vous ferez
diminuer d'office d'au moins 50 millions
d'euros par an les recettes commerciales
des trains d'équilibre du territoire ce
serait ainsi accélérer leur chute alors
que le rapport Duron vient d'en
souligner toutes les difficultés et je
ne parle pas des trains express
régionaux c'est donc une mesure
importante qui en même temps et je
voulais insister sur ce point a un effet
très limité sur la portée de la réforme
d'après l'étude d'impact seul 7 % des
trajets réalisés par autocar se seront
inférieurs à 200 km autant dire que la
fixation du seuil à 100 km serait alors
une mesure purement symbolique
d'ailleurs notre collègue à l'Assemblée
nationale Gilles Savari rapporteur du
volet mobilité avait lui-même indiqué en
première lecture que ce seuil pouvait
être discuté je tiens à rappeler que de
notre côté nous nous sommes efforcés de
nous rapprocher de la position de
l'Assemblée nationale en acceptant
l'ensemble de ces modifications sur cet
article hormis le seuil glissant y
compris puisque nous avons accepté de
rétablir la vie conforme de la raffire
j'espère donc que ces éléments vous
feront mieux comprendre la position du
Sénat sur ce point et peut-être même
pourrez-vous la prendre en considération
c'est l'un des atouts du bicamérisme que
nous que de pouvoir faire évoluer la
position des uns et des autres merci
madame le rapporteur alors Premier
Amendement de l'article sur l'article
2 monsieur bzino numéro
79 merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre nous nous estimons que la
libéralisation totale du transport par
autocar permettra au grands groupes de
transport dont la SNCF d'ailleurs avec
sa filiale idbus d'ouvrir librement des
lignes de transport collectif régulier
non urbain par autocar en concurrence
avec des services existants cela a été
dit et nous souhaitons le répéter qu'il
s'agisse des TER des des trains
d'équilibre du territoire ou des TGV
cela risque de réduire le service public
de transport ferroviaire de voyageurs en
supprimant des lignes des dessertes au
mépris de l'aménagement du territoire
aggravant ainsi la situation des petites
villes des villes moyennes des de
départements déjà fortement pénalisé par
la fuite en avant dans la mise en
concurrence des territoires alors vous
nous dites monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez répété tout à l'heure que cela
allait créer des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois combien exactement on sait
toujours pas et on ne sait toujours pas
non plus d'ailleurs combien d'emplois
seront supprimés dans le monde
ferroviaire à la suite de ces de ces
création de lignes d'autocard nous ne
pensons pas pour notre part qu'il soit
pertinent de faire entièrement confiance
à un secteur privé animé évidemment par
le seul moteur qui'est la recherche du
profit pour justifier de sa capacité à
répondre aux exigences d'un aménagement
équilibré du
territoire merci chers collègues alors
quel est l'avis de la commission l'avis
est défavorable nous avons déjà eu les
débats en première lecture bien sûr
monsieur le ministre même avis je mets
donc au voit l'amendement 79 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous avons maintenant deux
amendements identique le 63 madame
linman cet amendement vise à à moi
personnellement je suis défavorable à la
libéralisation mais à partir du moment
où elle a lieu il me paraît tout à fait
essentiel que les transports par car
soient prévus dans le cadre d'un service
public avec des des conventions qui sont
euh euh organisées avec la vie des
régions et des département concernés et
donc afin de s'assurer que la couverture
de ces lignes ne soit pas euh dans une
concurrence déloyale avec le transport
ferroviaire euh il est donc proposé
l'ouverture dans le cadre de convention
de service public c'est le but de mon de
mon amendement on avait déjà eu ce débat
en première lecture j'avais fait euh
état de la position du président de
l'Autorité ferroviaire qui nous
expliquait parce que monsieur le
ministre nous disait bah oui les
autocars il y a besoin parce que les
lignes de de de train sont de plus en
plus euh euh des AFF enfin il y a de
moins en moins de de passagers et cetera
l'analyse a montré que si les lignes de
train sont de moins en moins utilisé
c'est que les trains sont pas modernisés
c'est que les alttes sont mal organisés
que le confort et la sécurité sont
insuffisants et donc c'est ce que disait
d'ailleurs le président de l'Autorité
ferroviaire qui disait par ailleurs que
si le l'État ne modernise pas les tot
cela risque d'être assez mortifère pour
le train et il expliquait qu'en effet si
on libéralise l'écart et qu'on ne fait
pas d'effort dans le train ça va tuer
des entaire de Tet entre-temps le
rapport dur rond ne fait que confirmer
ce diagnostic manifestement on nous
explique que l'investissement vers les
Tet n'est pas la priorité que ça
coûterait trop cher et qu'à partir de là
youi tranquille on espère bien avoir la
concurrence du car j'ai jamais été
hostile à ce que dans certains cas il y
ait des cararts plutôt que des des
trains même si je privilégie toujours le
le train mais dans tous les cas de
figure ça doit se faire dans un cadre de
schéma de service public et de
convention de service public pour qu'on
nit pas une concurrence entre des sur
des secteurs rentables et qui et que
personne sauf le service public soit
amené à payer les services non rentables
d'où ma proposition réformiste d'avoir
une convention de service public pour
organiser ces lign de de cas quand elles
sont
incontournables merci Madame LM le
82 madame prunau vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le ministre chers
collègues cet amendement s'inscrit bien
dans l'intervention et dans le même
esprit que ma collègu Eveline Didier et
Marie noëlinman je suis déjà je me suis
déjà exprimé en première lecture sur ce
point vous dérégularisez votre
proposition votre texte dérégularise le
transport par autocard et viser à le
développer considérablement au au
détriment du transport ferroviaire
or monsieur le ministre vous l'avez
mentionné en première lecture la
possibilité d'ouvrir une ligne
d'autocard subventionnée de recourir à
une délégation de service public existe
déjà c'est un fait principalement dans
les zones rurales dont nous sommes ici
plusieurs représentantes et
représentants et cela marche bien cela
nous semble suffisant et conforme au
principes posés par la
décentralisation et la responsabilité de
l'État garant de l'unité de l'équilibre
de notre territoire il n'est pas besoin
je ne vois pas l'utilité à part faire
plaisir à un marché d'ouvrir à la
concurrence dans votre dans la
discussion générale de cet après-midi
monsieur le ministre vous au comme
argument la création
d'emploi c'est un argument qu'on utilise
aussi pour défendre
d'autres d'autres business mais moi je
pense que cet argument ne tient plus la
SNCF elle aussi peut créer des emplois
euh si vous voulez il suffit pour cela
euh de développer de restaurer notre
maillage ferroviaire qui est
exceptionnel ici en France mais très
souvent dégradé on le voit nous dans les
lignes
transversal en
province il y aurait la possibilité et
ce serait une ouverture pour les usagers
de développer les lignes transversales
euh parce que que ce soit en Bretagne ou
dans le Limousin quand il faut aller
d'un point A à un point B je vous assure
que ça reste toujours encore du parcours
du combattant donc moi je pense que
c'est cela que nous devrions développer
sur quoi nous devrions travailler de
plus la mise en concurrence des lignes
public par le privé ne se fera pas dans
des conditions équitables le principe de
péréquation entre lignes ou sur une même
ligne entre les trajets ne ne s'applique
au service public voilà merci quel est
l'avis de la
commission la commission spéciale a
donné donc deux avis défavorables sur
ces deux amendements qui sont des
amendements qui remettent en cause la
libéralisation et transports par autocar
prévu au présent
article monsieur le
ministre j'auris un avis défavorable
mais je vais faisant répondre aux
différents argumentaires qui ont été
évoqués sur les créations d'emploi ça
reste quand même un argument fort je
vous renvoie à l'analyse faite par
France stratégie 22000 créations
d'emploi direct donc je fait référence
puisque vous voulez une référence j'ai
toujours été prudent sur ces chiffrages
mais il sont là puisqu'il y a un
potentiel de création d'activité je l'ai
dit à plusieurs reprises la simple
comparaison des chiffres français avec
les chiffres espagnols allemand ou
britannique pour prendre trois pays
voisins le montre on passe de 100000 à
plusieurs millions entre 3 et 30 selon
les pays que je viens de citer donc il y
a un potentiel de développement et qui
n'est pas concurrent en totalité dual
bien au contraire qui est complémentaire
du rail à la fois parce que ce sont
d'autres formes de modalité parce qu'on
organise de la multimodalité et de
l'intermodalité la deuxième chose que je
voulais ici dire c'est que il s'agit
d'ouvrir et de simplifier la création de
lignes de transport privé et et c'est là
en effet mon désaccord avec les deux
amendements qui vient d'être qui
viennent d'être présentés ce qu'on
cherche pour
utiliser une métaphore déjà utilisée en
première lecture on cherche à ouvrir des
restaurants et vous me répondez
formidable il faut que ce soit possible
d'ouvrir des cantines scolaires il est
d'ors et déjà aujourd'hui mais il est
d'ors et déjà aujourd'hui possible
d'ouvrir du transport conventionné ça
n'est pas interdit il y a plein de
départements qui le font mais faut pas
que ce soit la seule possibilité ce
qu'on dit c'est que il doit être plus
simple d'ouvrir des lignes privées en
parallèle dans la limite des 100 km
glissants et donc là-dessus il faut pas
revenir en desessà du droit existant ce
qu'on cherche à faire c'est pouvoir
justement donner la possibilité à
l'initiative privée de se développer
parce qu'on pense qu'elle existe alors
après il y aura des lignes qui sont
rentables des liges non rentables les
lignes non rentables rien n'empêche une
collectivités locales de les
subventionner ce que font déjà des
collectivités mais le schéma que vous
défendez ce serait celui qui consiste à
dire on a des lignes aujourd'hui non
rentables qu'on va subventionner cela
existe et il y a des départements encore
une fois qui l'ont gén généralisé et qui
ont un budget et une ambition très forte
dans la matière et il s'agit absolument
pas de le remettre en contre puisque par
définition les lignes conventionnées
d'autocar qui existent elles ne seront
pas concurrencées par des partenaires
privés puisqu'elles ne sont pas
rentables par contre vous voulez
interdire par ailleurs que d'autres
formes de mobilité qui peuvent faire
l'objet d'une rentabilité privée s'ouvre
et là je ne partage pas de votre
philosophie pour aller au-delà je ne la
comprends pas je ne la comprends pas
parce que ça ne va en rien remettre en
cause ce qui existe aujourd'hui sauf à
considérer qu'on irait subventionner des
lignes qui pourraient exister sans
subvention et dans ces cas-là je peux
vous dire que si le service rendu est
aussi bon ce sera un gain pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens enfin pour
ce qui est des 100 km glissant contre
les 200 madame la rapporteur nous ne
perons pas no désaccord je crains sur ce
sujet mais je là aussi je veux que cette
réforme marche si vous faites les 200 km
fixes en quelque sorte vous les 200 km
glissant au fixe vous ne couvrirez pas
non mais à forcerie s ils sont glissants
puisque le 100 km glissant est couvre
une distance qui est supérieure au 100
km fix qui est notre position si vous
allez vers le 200 km glissant vous êtes
plus contre plus contraignant que le 200
km fixe encore vous n'ouvrirez de
manière libre que entre les capitales
régionales et vous ne permettrez pas
d'ouvrir un transport par autocar de
manière libre entre des villes moyennes
ce qui est regrettable et donc et donc
en l'espèce je pense que vous vous
reniez l'efficacité de la réforme ce qui
est dommage quand je compare là aussi ce
qui
existe en matière européen et bien
l'Allemagne a comme critère une heure de
transport qui équivaut à peu près au 100
km glissant que nous avons retenu je
pense que c'est un élément de
comparaison qui devrait être de nature à
vous rassurer donc en la matière
tiendrait bon en effet sur les 100 km
glissants parce que c'est une une
position qui est déjà plus ouvertes que
les 100 km fixes qui étaient
initialement
retenu merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
j'ai des explication de vote madame
Cohen tout d'abord
oui merci Madame la la présidente moi je
je pense que quand même quand on échange
comme ça des arguments il faut être il
faut être bien clair sur les arguments
qu'on qu'on échange je suis extrêmement
dubitative par les chiffres qui ont qui
ont été avancés par Monsieur le Ministre
22000 créations d'emploi donc par le
fait de création de lignes d'autocar je
trouve ça assez assez assez curieux je
me demande combien il va y avoir de
lignes d'autocar qui vont être ainsi
ouvertes combien il va y avoir de
chauffeurs ça me semble quand même des
chiffr un peu un peu fantaisist d'autant
que quand on veut créer effectivement
des lignes d'autocar qui en fait qu'on
le dise ou qu'on ne le dise pas vont
prendre la place de lignes qui sont
aujourd'hui à assuré par le les trains
et bien on va être amené à fermer des
lignes de chemin de fer et donc à
supprimer des emplois en plus je suis
très en désaccord avec les comparaisons
qui ont été faites à nouveau par
Monsieur le Ministre il nous dit d'un
côté vous nous parlez je reprends ses
propos et j'espère que je ne les
caricature pas vous nous par nous
voulons construire des restaurants et
vous nous parlez de cantine scolair
alors je voudrais avoir des explications
le service public ce sont des cantines
scolaires donc quelque chose qui
visiblement paraît un peu péjoratif dans
la dans la bouche de Monsieur le
Ministre et les restaurants ce serait le
nec plus ultra c'est-à-dire les les les
service d'autocar vous permettrez que je
sois très en désaccord avec ça et
d'autant plus en désaccord que il me
semble qu'on est en train de préparer la
cop21 c'est-à-dire de défendre une
planète avec un environnement
beaucoup plus sain alors j'aimerais
qu'on me fasse la démonstration que
un/art serait moins polluant que le
train et quand on met dans un quart 300
personnes on met combien dans un train
300 personnes pardon et on doit mettre
en place combien de quarts et puis enfin
il ne faut pas caricaturer nos propos
nous ne sommes pas pour l'interdiction
d'autocar il a effectivement des
endroits qui ne sont pratiquaes que par
les autocars mais là on n'est pas sur ce
débat là donc voilà ce que je voulais
souligner et on est donc complètement
désaccord avec les propos tenus par
Monsieur le Ministre merci Madame Cohen
madame linman vous avez la parole le
ministre vous dites que vous ne
comprenez pas notre raisonnement mais
moi je comprends trop bien le vôtre
c'est un vieux débat sur la place des
services publics dans notre pays depuis
Léon Bloom Léon Bloom expliqu que la
différence parce qu'il y avait déjà ces
débats fallait tout déréguler quand en
19 36 il y a une série de services
publics qui sont nés depuis cette
période làà on nous explique que
justement il faut laisser l'initiative
privée et puis que l'initiative publique
et ben elle doit s'occuper de ce qui est
pas rentable en tout cas celle qui doit
le porter vous le dites vous-même s'il y
a des lignes parentables que les
départements payent je rappelle que
d'ailleurs les lignes que vous ouvrez la
concurrence ne sont pas ni départemental
ni toujours régional elles peuvent être
national le principe du service public
c'est l'intégration dans une même
structure de ce qui est rentable et de
ce qui n'est pas et qu'à partir de ce
moment-là soit il y a convention de
service public ça veut dire que s'il y a
des lignes rentables ell participe à
leur part au financement des des lignes
non rentables qu'on j'ai choisi le train
ou le car pour ma part je privilégie
toujours le train mais à supposer vous
pensez qu'il faut prendre le quart et
ben le principe c'est qu'il y a
convention de service public pour que
les lignes qui sont mis à concurrence
contribuent financièrement aux lignes
déficitaires c'est ne pas privatiser les
bénéfices pour socialiser les pertes et
je comprends trop bien ce que vous nous
proposez aujourd'hui qui est
l'inverse merci madame linman monsieur
Laménie vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues c'est vrai
que en respectant j'irais votre
explication monsieur le ministre tout en
la respectant mais c'est vrai moi
honnêtement je ne suis pas non plus
convaincu du tout du tout du tout euh
bon on on n'est pas contre le les
autocars là où il y a pas de voie ferrée
bon d'accord complètement d'accord mais
par contre quand on voit et on a de
multiples exemples de de lignes fermées
ferroviaires remplacer alors on appelle
ça substitution routière c'est un mot
qui existe historiquement substitution
routière
euh depuis des années et ces dernières
années on en voit encore je vais prendre
un exemple que connaît notre collègue
evveline Didier euh en plus c'est pas
dans mon département même si c'est pas
loin c'est pas dans les ardines mais
c'est dans la Marne et la Meuse la féré
la ligne Chalon en Champagne Verdin donc
bah au mois de décembre ça s'est fait
fait en catimini pratiquement
euh on il y avait trois al tour aoraail
à peu près c'est certes pas beaucoup de
monde mais avec des horaires pas adaptés
ni rien il on roulait à 90 km/h et la
voix honnêtement elle était acceptable
après on a dit la SNCF a dit il y a
beaucoup trop de travaux ça coûte trop
cher il y a tant de millions d'euros de
travaux à faire euh donc on effraye les
élus et après naturellement on dit euh
ben on va mettre on remplace par par des
bus alors là le temps de parcours est
complètement allongé sur un exemple
parce que dès qu'on met un bus à la
place d'un autorail et ben allez là
c'est 40 minutes de plus alors on peut
pas parler de progrès donc là-dessus je
crois qu' à un moment donné il faut se
poser quand même les bonnes questions
puis quand même la notion de sécurité on
est quand même plus sûr dans un train
que dans que dans un bus il faut aussi
quand même dire la notion à la fois de
développement durable la notion de
sécurité bon je crois il faut quand même
être convaincu donc là aussi B je
soutiendrai ces amendements voilà chers
collègues monsieur Emorine a la
parole euh monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues moi je voulais
intervenir à cet instant parce que j'ai
présidé une commission qui s'appelait
l'économie le développement durable et
l'aménagement du territoire je voudrais
vous rappeler quelques chiffres quand
même le réseau ferroviaire en France
c'est 29000 km et vous avez 90 % des
trains qui circule sur 50 % du réseau
donc le débat que nous avons aujourd'hui
est un débat assez important puisqu'on
parle du transfert sur la voie routière
par les autocars mais à un moment donné
je crois qu'il faut être réaliste même
si je peux partager quelques analyses de
Madame linman sur le service public il
faut savoir à quel coûp il est ce
service public et à partir du moment où
on apporte une meilleure réponse avec
des autocard je vois pas pourquoi nous y
serions posés je vis répondre sur les la
COP 21 vous savez il est pas certain
qu'un bus pollu davantage que
l'entretien d'une voie ferroviaire où il
passe un train tous les jours au niveau
de l'impact environnemental je crois
qu'il faut réfléchir à ça mes chers
collègues al sur les 100 km
glissant que ma collègue n'y voit pas
une malise de ma part mais je partagerai
plutôt l'analyse de Monsieur le Ministre
parce que comme ils sont glissants il
peuvent aller à 150 200 soyez très
prudents parce que si' sont glissant les
200 s vous allez supprimer des trains
automatiquement bien alors je vais
mettre au voix les amendements
identiques 63 et 82 qui ont reçu deux
avis
défavorables qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas
adoptés alors deux amendements
maintenant qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le
80 monsieur
bzino bien Madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre on est toujours sur le le
même thème et une nouvelle fois nous
voulons exprimer notre point de vue sur
la généralisation du transport privé de
voyageurs par autocade car l'amendement
que nous défendons ici entant faire en
sorte que ce
développement soit au moins maîtrisé ne
se fasse pas au détriment du transport
ferroviaire ainsi nous proposons de
rendre plus claire la rédaction actuelle
du texte pour permettre au aux autorités
organisatrices de transport d'interdire
ou de limiter les services qui
porteraient atteinte à l'intérêt général
général et à la cohérence politique
parce que dans le service public il y a
aussi la question de l'égalité de
traitement sur le territoire c'est en
effet une question à notre sens très
politique à laquelle nous devons faire
face ces entreprises privées de
transport par essence n'ont pas le souci
du service public de l'enjeu écologique
ou de l'égalité territoriale ni même la
cohésion intermodale leur seul moteur
est bien la recherche de profit ce qu'on
peut comprendre pour une entreprise
privée le présent amendement vise donc à
rappeler que ces enjeux majeurs ces
questions d'équilibre économique et
territorial de prise en compte de
l'environnement et de préservation d'un
réel droit à la mobilité par un service
public efficient ne peuvent se passer
d'un contrôle et d'une régulation par
les autorités administratives
compétentes nous pensons donc que les
AOT doivent avoir de véritable marge de
manœuvre pour réguler voire interdire
certains services privés lorsque ceuxci
mettent en cause les principes que je
viens de développer merci merci qui
présente le 81 madame
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est
dans la continuité de ce que vient de
dire Monsieur Jean-Pierre bozinau et cet
amendement a déjà été débattu ici même
et adopté par le Sénat en première
lecture et nous vous proposons que
l'avis donné par l'ARF ne soit qu'un
avis simple puisque comme vient de le
rappeler Jean-Pierre bzinot nous
souhaitons que les AOT gardent la
maîtrise du développement de l'offre de
transport qu'elle soit par par autocard
car sinon cela risquerait de bouleverser
les équilibres économi du service
ferroviaire mais aussi les transports
organisés par ces mêmes
AOT de plus et il me semble là mes chers
collèg que vous devriez être sensible il
ne nous semble pas pertinent voire peu
démocratique d'imposer la décision d'une
autorités administrativ indépendantees
aux autorités élues sur des questions
aussi essentielles que les transports
dans une assemblée comme la nôtre où
nous sommes soucieux de l'aménagement de
notre territoire il me semble que la
disparition des services publics serait
très lourde de conséquence et
provoquerait un fort sentiment d'abandon
de relégation spatiale et sociale c'est
là le sens de cet amendement que je vous
propose d'adopter madame le rapporteur
votre
avis alors mes chers collègues
effectivement nous avions supprimé en
première lecture l'avis conforme de la
raffaire parce que nous considérions que
les collectivités territoriales étaient
CAPAES d'assumer Infiné la
responsabilité d'interdire ou de limiter
un service à partir du moment où bien
sûr il respectait le cadre fixé par la
loi et qu'il s'appuyait sur la vie
simple de la raffaire alors il semble
que à l'Assemblée nationale en tout cas
en commission spéciale bon nombre de nos
collègues ont émis des réserves sur
cette mesure craignant que l'ouverture
de lignes entière puisse être bloquée
par la seule décision d'une collectivité
territoriale des craintes qui me
semblent toujours infondées mais la
commission ion spéciale à la nouvelle
lecture ici au Sénat a voulu s'inscrire
dans une démarche qui soit plus
constructive à l'égard de ce qui a été
fait en commission spéciale à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est la raison
pour laquelle elle a donc laissé l'avis
conforme de la raffire et que bien
évidemment par contre elle est revenu
sur le seuil glissant des 200 km
s'agissant de l'amendement 80 il élargit
en plus considérablement la possibilité
d'interdiction ou de limitation d'un
service cela revient à vider la réforme
de sa donc l'avis est également
défavorable sur ces deux
amendements monsieur le
ministre je vais donc mettre au voix ces
deux amendements tout d'abord le 80 avec
deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté même vote pour le
81 je vous
remercie je vais mettre au voi l'article
2 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'article 2 est
adopté nous passons à l'article 3 avec
un amendement numéro
3 monsieur le
squarnc merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 3 complétant l'article 2
prévoit l'ouverture de ligne de
transport collectif régulier non urbain
par autoc cette évolution est de nature
a menacé la pérénité du transport
ferroviaire déjà fragilisée par la
concurrence de l'avion à Bacou de
l'autocar coteur et le covoiturage
l'étude d'impact du projet de loi reste
ainsi silencieuse quant au chiffrage des
conséquences au secteur ferroviaire
ainsi la dymétrie économique et
régulatoire dont le transport par
autocar bénéficie au détriment du
transport ferrovire risque de créer les
conditions d'une concurrence déloyale ce
risque se trouve aggravé par les
disposition destiné à éviter la
discrimination entre transporteurs
résidents et non résidents européens et
qui peuvent conduire à l'emploi de
travailleurs
détachés de plus on rappellera pour
mémoire que le droit fiscal français est
ainsi fait qu'il n'empêche nullement une
entreprise de proposer un service à
bascout et quasiment sans la moindre
marge opérationnelle dès lors qu'il
s'agit d'abattre la concurrence on peut
même très bien concevoir que certains
opérateurs de transport accepteront dans
un premier temps des pertes en capital
résolu par de nouveaux apports produit
de stratégie commerciale agressive
destiné à prendre place sur le marché
c'est le sens de notre amendement de
suppression je vous remercie je vous
remerci avis de la
commission avis défavorable madame la
Présidente ministre même avis alors je
mets au voix les deux l'amendement 83
pardon qui est pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le
84 madame Cohen
oui le le 84 est donc un amendement de
repli nous avons vu que l'article 3 fixe
les conditions de réalisation des
opérations de cabotage routier et nous
sommes donc en présence d'autre chose
qu'un simple article de coordination et
de mise en concurrence en cohérence
pardon des dispositions prévues par les
articles 1 et 2 du présent projet de loi
comme vient de le souligner Michel
lecornek en réalité l'article 3 entend
modifier la donne puisque la faculté
d'autoriser le cabotage devient une
simple autorisation ensuite les
dessertes régulières ne sont plus
d'intérêt national mais simplement
fondés sur les principes dont nous avons
vu la teneur lors de la discussion de
l'article 2 nous sommes donc dans une
forme de banalisation du cabotage ce qui
ne peut qu'exacerber la concurrence de
plus les modalités d'application des
règles en matière de transport ainsi
internationalisé vont être fixés par
promulgation d'un décret en Conseil
d'État prévu par le texte du projet de
loi et non par application du 3e alinéat
de l'article
l3421-2 actuel mais aujourd'hui la
question demeure quel droit viendra à
s'appliquer le droit social belge
allemand espagnol italien ou tout autre
droit cet article 3 c'est l'acceptation
de la loi du plus fort qui viendra vite
à s'appliquer sur l'ensemble des du
marché des autocars la libéralisation du
transport par autocard c'est en fait une
pour nous une piètre réponse que l'on
vient de trouver au problème d'inégalité
devant la mobilité et le transport qui
peuvent effectivement exister dans notre
pays mais je crois que nous avons eu
l'occasion de développer des argument
qui allit donc à l'encontre de cette
conception donc je ne serai pas plus
longue nous ne pouvons donc que vous
inviter à voter notre amendement qui
vise à supprimer les alinéas 8 à 10
voilà merci Madame Cohen madame le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission al
non je serai très courte la le débat a
eu lieu en première lecture et l'avis
est défavorable monsieur le ministre
également je vais mettre au voie
l'amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je vais mettre au voix l'article
3 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'article 3 est
adopté article 8 amendement 88 madame
pruneau merci madame la Présidente
l'article 8 tel qu'il a été amendé par
la droite de la même manière qu'en
première lecture suscite notre
opposition bien sûr en effet l'objectif
du texte voté par le Sénat est d'élargir
la possibilité pour les VTC de
stationner aux abords des gares et
aérogares sans oblig ation de retour à
la base en conséquence les VTC pourront
stationner aux abords des gares et
aérogares pour une durée définie par
décret et lorsqu'ils auront une
réservation préalable nous ne pouvons
soutenir cette proposition qui organise
pour nous une concurrence
déloyale la situation est aujourd'hui
vous le savez tous chers collègues
extrêmement tendu et les taxis à juste
titre craignent de ne plus pouvoir
exercer leur métier dans des conditions
économiquement viables ou acceptables
disons nous en avons eu surtout ici en
région parisienne la démonstration lors
de la grève des grèves et de la
manifestation de du jeudi 25 juin
manifestations qui ont également eu lieu
en province il faut rappeler que
l'origine des difficultés actuelles
vient et il faut rappeler et pour être
juste hein euh que l'origine des
difficultés actuelles vient de la LME
adoptée en 2009 sous le mandat de
Nicolas Sarkozi qui a démantthelé la
plupart des secteurs ou services au nom
de la concurrence libre et non faussée
cette loi a permis l'organisation de
cette concurrence frontale qui a
largement pénalisé les taxis et qui a
cristallisé des conflits importants or
maintenant l'une des dispositions dans
ce projet de loi
elle la désaffiliation de ces locataires
gérants de VTC du régime général de la
Sécurité sociale comme dans d'autres
secteur le statut d'auto-entrepreneur
des chauffeurs de VTC permet aux grandes
entreprises qui utilisent ce type de
transport de s'exempter complètement de
leur responsabilité d'employeur et
précarise encore un peu plus ces
travailleurs réduisant d'autant plus les
recettes de la sécurité sociale donc
pour toutes ces raisons chers collègues
nous demandons la suppression de cet
amendement quel est l'avis de la
commission alors il s'agit d'un
amendement de suppression de l'article
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable puisque l'article 8 tel
qu'il ressort des travaux de la
commission spécial apporte un certain
nombre de coordinations rédactionnelles
utiles merci m avis monsieur le ministre
donc deux avis défavorables je mets au
voit l'amendement 88 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le
89 madame Didier merci madame la
Présidente cet amendement de repli déjà
déposé en première lecture concerne très
directement l'activité de la société
uber avec son service uberpop vous nous
avez dit en première lecture que
l'adoption de cet amendement ne
changerait rien mais dans ce cas
pourquoi se priver d'un signe envoyé à
cette société pour lui montrer que les
parlementaires que nous sommes sont
déterminés à faire cesser ces pratiques
à fourcherie alors que le climat social
est particulièrement explosif même si
nous le savons tous il s'est apaisé en
effet ce service dit uber pop créer
créer une forme de concurrence déloyales
car il recourent à des particuliers qui
ne payent pas de cotisation sociale ne
sont pas dans l'obligation d'acheter une
licence ce qui est préjudiciablebl pour
eux-mêm et desloyal à l'égard des
conducteurs professionnels depuis le 1er
janvier 2015 les textes légaux visent à
interdire l'activité duber mais cette
société cherche à outrepasser cette
cette interdiction profitant de faille
législativ la société uber a soulevé
deux questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité dont l'une portant
sur la régulation des tarifs cette
société a également déposer deux
plaintes auprès de la Commission
européenne le but évident de ces
procédures est de gagner du temps pour
installer la marque et assécher le
vivier des taxis nous appelons les
pouvoirs publics à tout faire pour que
l'interdiction de l'application uberpop
soit effective nous savons que le
gouvernement a pris des mesures
peut-être pourvez-vous nous donner des
précisions monsieur le ministre nous
constatons qu'une telle interdiction a
été possible dans d'autres autes pays
comme en Allemagne ou au Royaume-Uni
notre amendement vise donc si ce n'est
pas à mettre fin à une situation
insupportable pour la profession au
moins à envoyer un signal clair à à
cette société et ne nous privons pas de
le faire merci alors l'avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur oui
madame la Présidente ma chère collègue
donc l'esprit de cet amendement que vous
avez déjà déposé et dont on avait
débattu en première lecture et qui avait
été rejeté vise en réalité les services
comme uberp
qui m en relation des passagers des
particuliers qui ne sont pas des
chauffeurs professionnels cette activité
est illégale et s'apparente à une
activité de faux taxis malheureusement
comme je je vous l'avais déjà indiqué en
première lecture la précision de cet
ajout professionnel au titre de VTC ne
changera rien à la difficulté en effet
la loi prévoit déjà bien dans le code
des transports des compétences
professionnelles pour les conducteurs de
VTC il y a donc un problème non pas dans
la clarté de la loi mais tout simplement
dans l'application de la loi alors il
convient en outre d'attendre ce que fera
la Cour de cassation et peut-être le
Conseil constitutionnel sur la question
préalable de constitutionnalité qui a
été transmise au sujet de l'article de
la loi tevenou qui interdit notamment de
mettre en relation des particuliers avec
des conducteurs qui ne seraient pas des
professionnels en attendant il est
toujours possible pour la police des
transports et plus que possible et bien
d'appliquer la loi et de faire en sorte
que l'on verbalise les conducteurs
uberpp qui donc là aussi il faut
respecter d'un côté la légalité de
l'autre côté
l'illégalité merci madame le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
oui je voulais peut-être préciser après
les événements de la semaine dernière en
effet quelle est la politique du
Gouvernement en la matière
et ce que nous comptons mettre en œuvre
d'abord bien repréciser les choses vous
l'avez mentionné je vous le redis ici
uber pop est un service qui est illégal
dans le sens où il a recours à une
catégorie qui n'existe pas en droit
positif qui reconnaît les taxis ou les
véhicules avec chauffeur donc uberpp qui
est une pratique de covoiturage détourné
n'est pas conforme au droit français et
donc aujourd'hui c'est un sujet en effet
de renforcement des contrôles nous avons
fait plusieurs contrôles qui ont conduit
d'ailleurs à des jugements qui ont
reconnu cette illégalité et ont
condamner d'ailleurs les dirigeants du
berpop en leur demandant de se conformer
à la loi et nous avons réitéré la
semaine dernière notre souhait de
précisément faire retirer l'application
uberpop et que ce service donc soit
stoppée la centrale a été poursuivie
notamment pour pratique commerciale
trompeuse dès octobre 2014 uber a été
condamné et donc c'est la procédure
d'appel qui a rendu justement par son
caractère suspensif a permis à uber de
continuer à opérer malgré ses jugements
les chauffeurs sont systématiquement
verbalisé et donc nous le faisons déjà
c'est pour ça que je vous redis que en
droit positif le l 31 22-7 et 31 22-8 du
code des transports dispose bien que les
conducteurs des VTC sont des
professionnels et donc votre amendement
est satisfait par ces deux articles mais
donc nous entendons bien ici faire
appliquer la loi le ministre de
l'Intérieur a annoncé un renfort en
passant de 80 à 280 policiers les cont
pour effectuer les contrôles afin de
verbaliser les chauffeurs il n'en
demeure pas moins que les violences que
nous avons connu la semaine dernière
sont absolument intolérables et
inadmissibles elles feront d'illeurs
aussi l'objet de sanction puisque il ne
convient pas de se faire justice
soi-même même dans le cas que nous avons
évoqué enfin je voudrais malgré tout que
ce qui s'est passé la semaine dernière
et les points que je viens de rappeler
sur particulier uber pop ne nous
conduisent pas à revenir endà de ce qui
a été établi par le droit et donc à
confondre uber et uberp on ne doit pas
revenir compte tenu d'ailleurs du
service qu'il représente et des emplois
qu'ils ont créé sur la création sur les
les sociétés de véhicules avec chauffeur
qui fournissent un service lequel est
encadré avec des conditions de formation
et euh des conditions d'exercice de la
profession je pense que cet équilibre
qui a été trouvé et de nature à donneré
une place à chacun dans le dans le droit
c'est pourquoi aussi et en vertu de euh
la volonté constamment réitérée par le
gouvernement qu'il y ait un équilibre
euh entre les différents professionnel
et une égalité de traitement j'aurai une
position défavorable sur l'article 8
parce que nous avons par les
dispositions qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement rétablit justement des
mesures d'équilibre en corrigeant la loi
dit tevenou sur le monopole des taxis
dans les aéroports et en restaurant
précisément les conditions qui sont de
manière normale apposé au VTC en cas de
de prise en charge et donc l'article 8
tel qu'il est rédigé qui sort de votre
commission spéciale revient mettre un
biais et donc revient sur notre souhait
qui est d'avoir un parfait équilibre
entre les VTC d'une part et les taxis
d'autre part je voulais apporter ces
éléments à la fois de contexte et puis
de position générale du gouvernement
pour dire que nous sommes favorables
donc au taxis et au VTC dans un souci
d'équilibre nous sommes favorables aux
équilibres de la loi d'octobre 2014 tel
que corrigé par le gouvernement qui
venait rétablir un élément de
d'incohérence qui avait subsisté nous
continuerons à sanctionner les pratiques
illégales et nous avons renforcé le
contrôle contre burpp mais nous
souhaitons pas aller plus
loin madame Didier oui euh merci madame
la Présidente écoutez au vu des des
explications qui nous sont données comp
tenu des derniers événements euh sachant
que notre amendement 98 portes sur uberp
je le
retire bien alors le
90 monsieur le
squarnc merci présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur sarnc est-ce que je
peux vous interrompre le président de la
commission spéciale voulait prendre la
parole je ne l'avais pas vu merci de 2
minutes voilà oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Je pas allonger le
débat sur la question VTC taxi pour
autant j'ai du mal à vous suivre quand
vous parlez d'équilibre
on est sur un secteur pour lequel on a
le sentiment que le gouvernement alors
vous me direz que c'est le cas de tous
les gouvernements mais quand même ne
propose au Parlement de légiférer qu'à
l'occasion des conflits et pour apaiser
tel ou tel des lobby c'est le cas de
tous les gouvernements je viens de le
dire à l'instant mais quand même il y a
6 mois une orientation Ava été prise 6
mois plus tard on y revient vous nous
parlez d'équilibre il ne faut pas nier
une réalité dont tout le monde do avoir
conscience ici c'est que dès lors que
l'amendement sur le retour à la base qui
était une
disposition se trouve modifié
sensiblement et qu'on enlève la
possibilité de rester dans un aéroport
dès lors qu'il y a une réservation pour
un client suivant dès lors qu'on oblige
le VTC à revenir à la base on tue une
partie de la profession c'est le choix
du gouvernement c'est le choix de
l'Assemblée mais il faut être simplement
lucide sur ce point
particulier merci Monsieur Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE je vous prie de m'excuser encore
une fois
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement entend supprimer le 15e
alinéa de cet article qui fait
disparaître l'affiliation obligatoire
aux assurances sociales du régime
général des conducteurs de voitures
publiqu je voudrais insister
particulièrement sur le cas des
chauffeurs de VTC enfin ceté déjà au vu
de lactualité brûlante de cette
catégorie la société
uberpp pour ne pas la nommer dont les
dirigeants viennent d'ailleurs d'être
mis en examen par la justice réalise
chaque année des milliards dollars de
bénéfice en passant allègrement outre le
droit du travail en précarisant
continuellement les chauffeurs qu'ils
embauchent et en
institutionnalisant la fraude fiscale
cette mise en application du libéralisme
le plus sauvage a d'ailleurs conduit ces
derniers jours au violence affrontements
queon sait l'amendement que nous
défendons vise à s'opposer à une remise
en cause des garanties sociales des
conducteurs qui serait la conséquence
directe d'une désaffiliation au régime
général de sécurité sociale au-delà du
fait que les finances du régime général
pastirai encore davantage d'une
diminution du nombre d'affiliés il
apparaît contradictoire de reprocher au
régime de sécité sociale des
indépendants le RSI ces
dysfonctionnement et d'exclure du régime
général plus protecteur cette catégorie
de chauffeur c'est pour ces raisons que
nous vous invitons à voter cet
amendement de suppression
merci madame le
rapporteur alors mon cher collègue la la
suppression à laquelle procède cette
alinéa que vous remettez en cause est
purement rédactionnelle en effet le
statut du locataire taxi a été supprimé
par la loi d'octobre 2014 seul
subsistent les cas des coopératives déjà
prévu par le 13e alinéa de ce même
article du code de la sécurité sociale
donc l'avis est un avis défavorable sur
votre amendement gouvernement même avis
donc je mets au voie l'amendement 90
avec deux avis de oui monsieur lequ il
est
retiré je vais donc mettre au voix
l'article 8 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est
adopté voilà pour les débats des
sénateurs autour du projet de loi Macron
projet de loi croissance activité
égalité des chance économique qui été
donc examiné en nouvelle lecture par le
Sénat vous avez pu entendre leurs
échanges nourris autour de la
libéralisation du secteur des transports
notamment autour de la libéralisation du
secteur des autocar dont le gouvernement
attend la création de 22000 nouveaux
emplois vous pouvez toujours voir et
revoir toutes les séances sur notre site
sur publicusa.fr très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires samedi